elite à sion et oui pour les 50 ppm paix
nous fait un cadeau exceptionnel trente
personnalités vont nous souhaiter un
joyeux anniversaire
n'est ce pas vincent cassel c'est bon tu
pars j'avais du mal mais que sa moue qui
par là haut est tout le temps mon poste
ça va être le plus bel anniversaire de
ta vie c'est pourquoi au parce que je
suis là j'aurai les anniversaires tmp en
cadeau j'ai un scoop
est ce que vous savez pourquoi aymeric
caron qui est végétarien va arrêter on
n'est pas couché non parce que
l'émission fini tartare mon cadeau pour
les 50 et pb ce que je vais essayer de
papa et le métro c'est une bonne
nouvelle
bonne nouvelle il était à fond de
l'église notre dame de bonne nouvelle
mais au genou n'a je souhaite bon
anniversaire de cinq ans même si vous
m'avez tout prix un la danse des épaules
c'est qui qui l'a inventé bah c'est bibi
oui je bonjour j'ai eu des bébés
vous avez sakho et vous cartonnez du
coup j'avais une question pour vous
savez quoi de réussir quelque chose moi
président de la république république n
3 5 8 9 et 11
situé sur la place de la république la
station est la sixième la plus
fréquentée du réseau bonsoir je souhaite
un joyeux anniversaire à tp qui est en
passe d'emporter qui veut gagner des
millions de téléspectateurs
c'est de nouveau au coeur bon
anniversaire à toutes les houlette de
tpe un peu faim quand ma gueule ici pas
question préféré que je veux faire de
tous ces années
coco mais craquer
pause en poussant pause on s'épanouit et
aujourd'hui on a cinq ans et ont fleuri
c'est magnifique
j'allais le couple tout de suite la
caisse ou coup la question qui mousse et
le feu que ces coquines bien sûr 100
français combien souhaite un joyeux
anniversaire à tpb en fantasmant sur et
n'aura pas mon cas elles sont bourse aux
jouets anniversaire touche pas à mon
poste
enfin une émission qui n'est pas
vulgaire pas comme miss france avec tous
ces petits cafés mais là c'est biatch
lingots que montrer leur schneck
bonsoir à tous et bonsoir à tout
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau du talent du
charisme mais énormément de beauté mais
à séparer de moi
joyeux anniversaire nous sommes jeudi 2
avril 2015 ce sont les cinq ans de
touche pas à mon poste
alors soit encore cinq ans et ce n'est
même pas un cliché clichés partager
libanaise la concertation été réalisée
en 1900 par hector guimard bon fraudeurs
autre sens commente hommes ont non
seulement en y versant bon surtout en
sont
jean louis charles marc non stop
je crois que ça car bon anniversaire je
sais pas pourquoi ça m'énerve
et quand je m'énerve je sais pas
pourquoi mais ça m'énerve encore plus
bas salut public
alors joyeux anniversaire touche pas à
mon poste et rigueur ces postérieur
valérie bénaïm gourmande
bonsoir tout de suite un reportage
intitulé drogue sexe et mafia les faces
cachées de touche pas à mon poste à voir
uniquement dans enquête exclusive
alors moi je vous souhaite un joyeux
anniversaire
cinq ans ça fait une belle somme nette
pourquoi je souhaite un bon anniversaire
à tpm p
d'autant plus que je sais que comme moi
cyril vous aimez les grands hubs au nom
des jeunes par new jersey nets succès
salut c'est nikos à la tomate oignon
lagaf' @ nikos officiel joyeux
anniversaire tmp hashtag anniversaire
hashtags encore attaqué pmp hashtag
#civsocial anniversaire cinq ans c'est
bien c'est lâche qu'on dirait que j'ai
quand on regarde mes dents oui
ggd dans deux n'a tout simplement pas du
candidat
un genre toi que je suis une émission de
télé qui fête ses 5 hors je suis je suis
je suis ep
jo ne sommes ni verseur tp même effet
mais répétés mais bon bon bon ami ben
quoi mais jouer les anniversaires tp un
pet ya cinq ans c'est pallium tu veux
savoir si derrière on voit lourd a omis
de nous tous
happy birthday tps était blonde à forte
poitrine qui m'intéressent enora malagré
et si tu n'es pas blonde ni à force cela
serait-il intéressé nora laissez-moi
vous narrer une pincée j'ai pensé
l'autre jour alors j'étais
tranquillement assis sur mon menton et
je me disais je les anniversaires tpm
t'es ok bonjour dégagée sur la nuque pas
trop sur les côtés ok un anniversaire
c'est quoi c'est quand tu fais de lait
un nom de ton anniversaire de quatre ans
aux gays j'aime la vie vous avez entendu
non certainement un mieux qui a crié la
drogue c'est mal ça les touche pas à mon
enfant je vous souhaite une bonne
anniversaire avec un gâteau bien grand
bien les coquins ou si vous plaidiez des
frites et la mayo maillot pas de maillot
des lions face à son était une amy
portes de l'enceinte du bois de boulogne
réalisé sous le règne d'henri 2 on a
cinq ans mais petit goûter
je vous dire là la saison prochaine on
va complètement changer le concept des
bissau oui mais cheryl et perruques
l'année prochaine on va les mettre à
l'envers
réagissez sur toto une poupée chérie tu
as de gilles verdez se déguise hashtag
j'ai ma perruque et ppc bénéfique de
chemises jaunes et noirs
la foule à bord du lac
à part toi moi
excellent
oh